hey people welcome to the Reuben report
I'm the human debt ceiling Dave ruin
I've got Kathy ladman and Jimmy door
with me and we have amazing breaking
news right this very second it looks
like a deal has been struck America is
not going to go into default at least
today probably in about a month that's
going to be my general prediction so all
right we're alive we're okay here we go
an interesting poll came out by Rasmus
and that half of Americans basically
believe that the founding fathers would
be disappointed in the way America has
turned out let's look at some numbers
34% of Americans believe if the founding
fathers came back today they'd view
America as a success that's a pretty low
number 49% say the founding fathers
would view the present day us as a
failure 51% of Democrats say failure 62%
of Republicans say failure and
177% say they aren't sure those numbers
seem pretty legit to me I think the
founding fathers would be rolling in
their graves right now if they saw what
was going on America are we a failure in
the eyes of the founding fathers I mean
who knows you know you look at what they
had I mean they you know they didn't
have Plumbing I mean so Plumbing they'd
feel they'd feel good you know the
plumbing is good yeah but some of the
other stuff really sucks um Jefferson
was a good from what I
understand he was was that documented
that's is what I've understand yeah but
he had people that were taking Tak it
out now we have a system chamber chamber
pot he had a seat warmer boy he had that
going on who needs that I can't I need a
door closed and a fan on me I need two
doors
closed my oh why are we talking about
this wow we all already my but it's
funny to see this is a pure continuation
of where we were at before the show
started the Republicans in that
statistic it said the Republicans what
was it 64% 62% of Republicans which is
interesting right because they're always
angry at people they don't love America
oh Barack Obama's not proud of America
why aren't you proud it turns out more
of them aren't proud of America than
anybody and usually the Republicans
usually love this country and why
shouldn't they they pay full price yeah
the point is but so that isn't that kind
of interesting that they they're the
ones who well but they can say that now
because they hate Obama so so much right
wouldn't they wouldn't they also say it
because well not only is there a guy not
in charge but they feel that Liberty is
being destroyed especially look at these
last Two Weeks It's All About Liberty
for them and healthare somehow poor
people getting healthare is affecting oh
and and also on the heels of gay
marriage and all these things that just
make them broyal and boil and Royal you
know they're just so furious at all this
movement forward they So speaking of gay
marriage so certain things that the
founding fathers would have never
imagined like gay rights and you know
equality for women and for black things
like that would they be you think they'd
be happy about that if they were able to
really think it through because they
wanted Liberty individual Li Liberty so
even though it didn't happen in their
time do you think things like equality
for gay people those type of things
would make them proud I think the yes I
think if you deconstruct the the
documents that that were written they
really Echo what's going on in the in in
those areas and I think those those men
because they were all men would um look
at it and you know maybe initially would
be like wow what the hell's going on
here but they would look at it and say
yeah this is progress this is what we've
written for if you take what we've
written and you move it forward you know
200 some odd years this is where we've
were if you take that I'm sure they
would be upset with the convergence of
religion and politics definitely
especially Thomas Jefferson who wrote
The Jefferson Bible which got rid of all
the stupid that screws up religion
right so yes I would think that they
would be horrified at what happened and
I think they would also be horrified at
the corporate money takeover of politics
I think they would be against that they
could not Envision the C Brothers being
able they didn't Envision televisions
and so they didn't understand how you
can control the message just with money
and right now the idea that money equals
Free Speech well some people have more
money so it's not really free is it
right so that that's a perfect segue to
my next thing because I want to know
what do you guys think they would think
about the Tea Party because the tea
party's whole thing was no taxation
without representation which goes to the
to the money issue uh they obviously
believed in that but I don't I don't
really think they would buy into a lot
of the tea party stuff now would they um
I can't see it these people are just
like they're so Wacko and they're so
completely off the charts and they're so
against everything else that is freedom
oriented I mean I just can't see how
they would appreciate that am I naive
why why don't some ancestors of the Tea
Party sue for the name back you know AR
they giving them a bad rep this was
about actual tea literally in water in
water uh and dressing up and blaming it
on the Indians the point is but that's
not come let's forget that part let's
forget about that kind of horrible
history of the Tea Party do I what I
think the founding followers would think
of the Tea Party yeah is that they would
think that they're crazy extremists that
they're not about Liberty they're
they're about small-minded narrow goals
that have anything to do with liberty
and it just goes to show you uh Dana G
make this point one time he talks about
how they say they're all about the
Second Amendment and if you got to have
the Second Amendment because when the
government comes to take your freedom
you're going to have your gun to defend
you well the government has already
taken away all their freedoms they're
listening to all their phone calls
they're they're reading their emails
they've taken away their now they can
give them indefinite detention so
they've taken away all their Liberty and
they don't give a they just want
their gun still so they just want their
guns They Don't Care About Liberty right
so to everything you just said though
the founding the founding fathers would
not that be that happy with ob no they
would be I think they would be horrified
they by the whole the whole thing they
knew the tyranny of governments they
knew the tyranny of dictators that's why
why they wrote the Constitution the way
they did but wasn't I mean tell me
wasn't a lot of it wasn't a lot of it
about religion initially a lot of the
Constitution a a lot of the the reason
that our country was formed it wasn't a
lot of it about well it was about they
got kic well the pilgrims were so
puritanical they got kicked out of
Europe for Christ's sake that's how
crazy they were so so yeah they came
here and that's where we get this
puritanical work ethic which
leads us to work harder than anybody
else in the rest of the world without
Healthcare right that's really we work
harder I mean harder than the Chinese uh
yeah can you believe it you haven't seen
videos from the Apple factories those
guys are working pretty hard I guess
it's over an average you know I'm
guessing most of the Chinese are rural
they're not working so hard oh uh final
thought of this what what do you think
they would think about our sort of bush
Clinton Dynasty you know what I mean
we've had two Bush presidents we're
probably going to have another Clinton
and we left England because we wanted to
escape kings and queens and it's like
doing it to ourselves right here yeah I
mean it does it does seem rather akin to
that but I mean I guess the big
difference here is that they're elected
and um there they were just you know
kind of uh appointed because of their
bloodline but doesn't it seem like
they're some sort of appointed Hillary
seems like she's being anointed rather
well yeah because like I think back to
what Jimmy said it's about having money
and being able to like uh kind of stage
a stage a camp cign where you can get
yourself out there and they I'm sure
there were were many other qualified
people who aren't able to get themselves
out there and put themselves in in a
position to be elected and I think
that's unfortunate you know your point
about how they would feel about the bush
do you know 20 out of the last 33 years
a guy named Bush had a key to the front
door of the White House yeah 20 out of
the last 33 years so I and now we're and
now we're going to have a Clinton again
so yes this this political Dynasty is
not good for America I I think that's
obvious and um I think they would be
horrified at that too I mean that
Washington left the presidency after one
term because he didn't want to have that
kind of stuff happening yeah that's a
good a lot of good points and you know
what support Malia Obama in 2022 that's
where this is all heading so James Woods
Hollywood actor for movies like contact
and casino he's done voices in The
Simpsons family guy and a zillion other
things uh he's taken a a sort of hard
turn right politically and he's sharing
his thoughts
on Twitter and people are not happy with
them let's read some of the tweets this
President is a true Abomination to have
barricade the World War II vets but
allowing illegal aliens privilege and
then there's a link to USA article I
think we got
a read I can actually read that from
where I'm sitting I think we got a
couple more here in then so then uh
people have been writing him saying this
person said dude aren't you worried
about you know ever working again
because Hollywood is such a liberal
elitist town and he wrote I don't expect
to work again I think Barack Obama is a
threat to the integrity and future of
the Republic my country first so just
real quick I do want to tell you that I
asked James Woods to be on the show and
uh he said he'd like to do it but he
only wants to stick to Twitter where he
can control the message right now as
opposed to you come here and we can we
can edited it and really screw you up my
God I sort of even though I don't agree
with a lot of what he's doing I sort of
respect that he's putting himself out
there and we have so few people in the
public sphere that do do that
uh Jimmy you're I can sense a headache
coming out of you right now well I mean
I expect someone taking a courageous
stand that's not a courageous stand to
side with racists and and to
say to just sling unsubstantiated crap
the last
President we all accept the fact that
him and his team lied us into an illegal
War but somehow national health
insurance is going to subvert democracy
right so that's the kind of just like go
away you're just an idiot it's get it's
that's not that's what I'm talking about
we have to have an agreed set of facts
to that we deal with so if you're going
to say that first of all he didn't close
the goddamn Memorial the
Republicans Clos down the government and
that's part of the goddamn government
that's what how they do that and I saw
some guy on but he's upset about the
World War II Memorial but he's not upset
about the cancer patients who aren't
going to get their trials he's not upset
about the kids on Wick who aren't going
to get their formula he's upset about
the World War II mus which shows what a
lightweight he is James Woods
turns out having all the money in the
world doesn't make you a good person
right exactly do you think he's going to
be able to work again when you do this
in Hollywood we're all in Hollywood
plent people he'll never work again just
like Mel Gibson right exactly well up
but he doesn't work that much he works
he he does work he can work yeah you
know what anytime anybody can make
anybody else some money in Hollywood
that person works and that's that it
doesn't matter but I have to say and I
don't agree with anything that he said
yeah um that when people and I am so on
the other side but you know when people
um have said horrible things about Bush
which I think deservedly so that's okay
but when somebody says the opposite and
we have to have freedom of speech even
for the idiots even for the idiots we
have to have freedom of speech and you
know I remember one time years ago I was
in South Carolina doing a gig and we
were going to um we having brunch and
and we had to leave soon because they
were closing the streets for a clan
March and I thought oh that's terrible
and then I thought no no this is good
this is good this should be seen it
needs to be seen it needs to be out
there people need to say these things
out loud so you can see what they are
yes I agree that who they are did you
guys know that James Wood is considered
one of like the most hundred uh most
intelligent people in the United States
he's like a menza like top tier person
does that change your opinion that well
that just goes to I know some people in
Mena and some of the dumbest
ERS I've ever met yeah that has no
correlation with being smart to having a
high IQ to be able to pass that Mena
test that has nothing to do with Buckley
he he was
really but he was politically insane and
you know it's just when you say I I I
you know I admire someone for expressing
an informed that's not an informed
opinion that has nothing to do the thing
he's upset about has nothing to do with
Barack Obama it's like there are plenty
of reasons to criticize Barack Obama
Dave that's not what I'm upset about say
horrible things about Barack Obama but
they're accurate they're not made up out
of whole cloth and they don't have an
undertone of racism right now
granted that was only one tweet he has
written a lot of stuff about the NSA and
all the other stuff that we all don't
like that the NSA which was started the
he should be upset at the Patriot Act
which allowed the NSA to do that so
to pretend that this is just Barack I
mean you should criticize Barack Obama
but again pretending that it's this
Administration that it's somehow going
to be a threat to the F get that and the
Patriot Act was Bush's right of
Democrats and Republicans got but it was
during it was during his administration
was it everybody except for one
Congressman or something or one
congresswoman something I'm sure it was
one congresswoman yeah do just the name
of the Patriot Act piss of
course theistic you know I mean yeah but
wasn't that the beauty of the Patriot
Act if you're not a patriot if you get
the hell out yeah yeah do we owe this
guy any credit whatsoever because at
least he's not going to the other main
things the anti- women stuff and the
anti-gay stuff he's at least going to
the policy stuff even if we don't agree
with it for him to say that about the
World War II Memorial just exposes him
for to be uninformed it exposes him to
be in a light leming yeah a leming right
what he's about his smart as Sarah Palin
in this instance and so he's just you
just dismiss him but didn't didn't Obama
didn't the administration decide that
they were going to be the ones that were
going to block actually blockade the
thing and lock it isn't that isn't that
I'm pretty sure the government shut down
right but all the parks in every state
are closed all everything is closed
government all the naal memorial are
closed everything's closed well they'll
be open in about two hours so we'll be
our right but can I can I say on the
heels of that I saw some report on TV
where some guy was complaining that you
know that some guard wasn't letting him
into the World War II Memorial and you
know I hate flag pins I hate flag
pins first of all you um I don't
care um they've become me meaningless
because everybody wears a flag pin
because what if they see me not wearing
a flag pin so they become meaningless
anyway so but this guy was wearing a
flag like a flag that waved in his
pocket it was oh he had a legit flag wow
that's a true it was hilarious that's
funny it was like cartoonish well I
always I refer to those the people who
wear the flag lapel pins that's like an
detector right it's like I can
tell I can tell you're you're still an
and and it you know it's it's
it's the guy you're tell you're trying
too much like if I was an enemy of the
United States and I don't want anybody
to know it that's the first thing I
would do is put that who was it that was
running for a president that didn't want
to wear the pen and everybody was was it
Ron Paul one of these guys was who it
was oh it was it was Obama it was
President Obama you see but now he but
now he wears the flag now he wears it
now he wears the pen but now he wears it
all right that's upsetting let's move
from the zombies of politics to the
actual zombies that we all like The
Walking Dead return this week to Bonkers
ratings but before we get into that if
you haven't watched let's let's look at
some
zombies n stand
there okay maybe I should have given
some sort of Parental warning there or
something I'm not sure you know can I
just say what upsets me the most about
that clip is I went up for one of
those and I can't believe that that
woman was cast I can't believe it well
it was connections she knew somebody at
the studio uh anyway The Walking Dead
came back the the premiere Out rated
Sunday Night Football which is
completely crazy yeah let's look at some
of the ratings no I'm kind ofad so the
season 1 Premiere had 5.4 million season
2 7.3 season 3 10.9 and season 4 16.1 I
mean if any network show got 16.1
million viewers they would be absolutely
thrilled and what is and and and what
like what would a normal hit show get on
a network do you think I have no idea I
mean if you get 10 million now on a on a
network show you're in pretty good shape
I think big bang the is the number one
comedy it gets probably like 20 million
something like that so I mean 16.1 is
huge wow 16.1 it's like a third of the
audience that All in the Family used to
get so it's a a huge hit nowadays isn't
that something well there was only so
many things there only three channels
back then right so now yeah yeah uh so
uh does this just show you how
television's changing and that these
other channels like AMC are actually
just making better stuff than you know
in our old school Minds we keep thinking
that CBS ABC and fox are going to make
all the good stuff well I think when you
when you open up a Marketplace generally
you get more competition and people you
know kind of rise rise to the top you
know or some some do anyway um I mean I
love the stuff that's on cable and I
don't have time to watch everything that
I want to watch I was watching The
Walking Dead for a while and I was so
into it and all of a sudden at one point
like I imagined it might happen with
porn I just like went I've had
enough you know and it was just like
again you know the zombies they're
getting stabbed and there's blood coming
out and then people are eating each
other I mean it's just I guess I guess
the story lines and the characters
stopped grabbing me but apparently yeah
they're grabbing a lot of people and
those zombies like they just like look
they're lining up on purpose to get
slaughtered it's like so does being a
zombie also lower your IQ a couple of
points like they yes your brain is
affected and you just keep walking to
the food you just want to feed oh is
that it yeah you just want it's a
metaphor though it's a metaphor for for
the tea party I think well yes for a lot
of the public I think that you just kind
of keep walking towards the disaster
even though it's inevitable o I like
that what what does it say that it's out
rating football though our national P
time I think that's great you think
that's something I am I have never been
a football fan I've just never grasped
the game I like I love baseball I really
like basketball I'm not a football fan
and I'm not a I'm not a fan of the fans
of football you know I think that that's
really what does it for me funny and I'm
just like tired of like I'm just tired
of people like thronging to it and a lot
of people I I like and love love really
like football butes do it for me and I
like that something's superseding it I
really like that wow that is something
is uh is The Walking Dead the best
commercial that the NRA could ever have
because in that world you need a gun and
every time I'm watching that I'm
thinking this is sort of why I believe
guns should be legal because I have far
more belief that we're going to have a
zombie invasion or an alien invasion
than the government is going to come get
me you are you buying my crazy you you
you believe I think a zombie invasion is
more likely than the government coming
together tell me how you arri with all
the you know all these pesticides all
these the things we're eating you know
think biological UND yeah sort of like I
Am Legend kind of stuff and I'm going to
need a gun to to save myself crazy you
know what if things get that bad the way
they are in that show I don't want to be
around because my whole day is getting
up and killing zombies I just don't want
it I was like oh God like another day of
this where's the life quality I mean
I'm with you Jimmy isn't it though
wouldn't you you know the NRA they
should be using this and saying look
zombie apocalypse da I don't think
you're making a serious point
so uh the Alien Invasion what about the
Alien Invasion we're going to need
weapons if some goes down no I
think we I actually go the other way I
actually think we have a bigger chance
of the government coming and taking us
away uh especially now with the you know
they can put you in jail without any
charges forever they did it already they
can they've tortured our own uh Soldier
Chelsea Manning right for a year
tortured them president knew about it
didn't give a and uh so I I I'd be
more I'd be more afraid of the
government than of
zombies what what if the government like
calls you in for an email and then they
just like correct the
punctuation they're like Jimmy you're
the only one still using salutations in
an email no one uses salutation I still
do I still use most I try to say hello
are very professional and then I try to
say thanks in my name at the bottom you
know you did you wrote me an email
yesterday you wrote XO at the end like
Kiss okay well sometimes sometimes it it
has a special me he saves it for certain
people but yeah I don't now I thought it
was a little uncomfortable okay it was a
bit much all right let's move on to
zombies of Another Kind McDonald's uh
they are taking the toys out of Happy
Meals uh that's right they're putting
books in happy meals that sounds like
the worst thing I can possibly imagine
they're making them unhappy meals
they're making them truly unhappy meals
for a limited time McDonald's will
distribute 20 million self-published
print books and happy meals to coincide
with national family literacy day also
doesn't sound like a great day uh let's
take a look at the McDonald's press
release McDonald's will offer books in
print for Happy Meal customers providing
more than 20 million books to families
across the US throughout the twoe Happy
Meal books offer families will be able
to enjoy four original books featuring
McDonald's Happy Meal characters of
course each limited edition book brings
nutrition imagination and play to life
in a fun way so yes these are books that
were made by their PR Company really to
push their stuff is this just like the
worst kind of they're trying to pretend
this is about making kids read and so
disgusting yeah just you're you're a
mother what do you think about this me
well I haven't eaten McDonald's in years
and and Milan does not eat McDonald's my
daughter does not eat in McDonald's
either and in fact we taught her when
she was little to say that George Bush
and Ronald McDonald kill
people and um but can she read how else
will she learn to read if not through
McDonald's you know what they should
instead of changing the prize that goes
along with the meal change the meal get
rid of the poisons and the pink
slime and whatever else they're whatever
else they're using in their food I think
it's disgusting that they lure kids in
and parents become uh susceptible to
this and just to shut their kids up and
to save some time take them to this
place it's horrible it's horrible for
them but but isn't this the reverse lure
then because you're taking the toy away
and now putting a book yeah but you're
putting a book that has toy characters
in it so it basically is is plating it's
plating somebody out there and then
they're just keep they're introducing
the characters in a different way so
that the characters will come back and
the kids will be familiar with the
characters and want more of the
characters right so would you be more
okay with it with it if these were legit
books not made by McDonald's uh you know
PR Company yeah I mean I I think a kid
would enjoy opening up a Happy Meal and
thumbing through warn peace or maybe the
light in the forest or something yeah
yeah you know maybe catch her in the Ry
get a kid ready for the word stuff
like
that that that would work for you yeah
yeah I think so but yeah it's it's the
point is the food though yeah so we're
all agreed that the food the food is
just awful but how do you stop it how
how do you stop sending kids to these
places whether they're getting toys or
books the food is awful either way and
everyone knows you I don't think the
food is so horrible have you seen the
pink slime videos yeah but they don't
from what I understand is that they
don't put that in their hamburgers
anymore now it's out for the last couple
months yeah um yeah the problem is you
know the way we treat you know beef and
cattle I that's real the real problem uh
you know I think you know you get a ham
sandwich or a cheeseburger I think
they're pretty much the same thing right
on White Bread that's not good for you
and all the Buns have a lot of sugar in
them I mean they produce things and you
know the mass produced they do it in a
cheap a cheap cost-efficient way right
you know fried things a lot of fried
things on the menu and the McNuggets
that which have ingredients in them in
the United States that are illegal in
Europe yeah that are partly used to make
yoga mats literally so they have non
food stuffs in their food and a judge
referred to it as Franken food yeah so I
don't go for the chicken nuggets but I I
don't know I mean is is if you yeah if
you take your kid and give him a Happy
Meal every day that's not good who's
feeding their kids like that a lot of
but people do people do it's it's a
socioeconomic a lot of people look at
the Obesity amongst kids oh God it's so
it's so sad and now that we have
Obamacare shouldn't we be more concerned
about everyone's health because now
we're all paying in together right well
we don't we you know what yes I agree we
were by the way we were all paying in
before we were people were going to the
emergency room and it cost a lot more
but it seems like we're all going to be
in it a little bit more now doesn't it
yeah it does certainly does uh uh I you
know I saw Super Size Me did you see it
I haven't seen that and I heard it was
I'm reallyy good so yeah I mean that's a
guy who ate three meals a day at
McDonald I mean you you're not supposed
to do that you know so if you I mean if
you if you had Corn Flakes three times a
day I'm sure they would have some shitty
yeah but you had if you have healthy
food three times a day if you had you
know vegetables and salad and Grains and
protein and that three times a day would
be great M right but isn't it just about
money we talk about
it's just about money and access and
education and all that it's hard to
prepare healthy I don't cook anymore I
really I mean what do you eat Tom is a
really good cook HB but when he doesn't
but when he doesn't cook I mean I
scramble I mean I I used to cook and I
say to Tom I said I know I used to cook
I I lived alone until my late 30s I know
I used to cook and um but I forgot I
mean I really forgot how and now I have
a very thin repertoire you know my you
cheese oh do you still eat do you still
eat meat and stuff I do I eat I haven't
eaten beef in a long time I eat chicken
and I eat F chicken turkey and fish and
I know that's not certainly a perfect
way but that's something I I can't stop
eating sushi I have to keep eating and
crab I get I like crabs you like you
have crabs yeah I have C from what I
understand all right so eat some chicken
turkey and fish and try reading a real
book and uh and see what happens okay
let's move on so uh This is Wild charity
Navigator which is a website uh for
determining which Charities operate the
most effectively they've come out with
an annual study of CEO pay where they
ranked people and it's uh it's a long
list but 11 Charities pay their CEOs
over a million dollars and we just we
picked a couple of them here five let's
take a look so these are Charities that
pay more pay their CEOs and their
leaders million so American University
it's their like Foundation Metropolitan
Museum of Art the Heritage Foundation
that's uh your buddy what's his name s
De yeah uh the national Center for
missing and exploited children and the
Boys and Girls Club of America yeah
that's that last one you know I've been
to Boys and Girls Clubs okay they're
horrible they are so so spare I mean
it's a great service where you can have
a place for your kids to come basically
for free and play and be and you know
and have you know be in a good
surroundings but they're really they're
not pretty they're not dirty but they're
not pretty and what's served to them in
forms of snacks are not great and for
that charity so the CEO there is making
over a million dollars just I I think
that's disproportionate yeah so the
median CEO salary uh for all the ones
that charity Navigator looked at was
about
$126,000 uh for large Charities that had
more than 13.5 million in annual
expenses uh the median pay was
$244,000
um but this seems completely crazy right
now I think what they would argue is
they need the best of the best you know
that's what they would argue and that
otherwise you get this brain drain
because if you don't pay the CEOs enough
they you're not going to get the right
people in that can make it as good of an
organization that's what Mother Teresa
used to say that's right you know I'd
love to do the work but come back to me
with another offer you got to pay me so
is that is the brain drain argument you
you just don't buy that at at any level
whatsoever not for charity no you go to
work for a charity I mean there's lots
of committed people that's all
that's about people wanting more money
and being GRE taking a million dollars
from a charity that is so that's
$20,000 a week right 20 yeah that's
$20,000 a week wow it is yes 20 a week
so that's $5,000 a day right that's more
than Jank makes
whoa well you like that one you know I
mean maybe I'm naive but I guess I
expect someone who works for a charity
to have some amount of altruism and um
at this level but also yeah you know
what is too much mean it really depends
on what your perspective is I mean like
I could say yeah I think that if they
make like $250,000 a year I think that's
a that's a fair amount but like who am I
to say that I think you're I think
you're just as qualified as anyone else
to say that I I would say that I would
say that hey we'll give you a salary
that puts you in the upper 2% is that
enough right is that enough so that's
the question would these people people
that are doing this for over a million
dollars not do it for
$500,000 which I would be pretty happy
the Boys and Girls Clubs that half
a million yeah I'm going back I'm going
back to I'm going to work for for
tobacco that's right yeah so can we just
not play on on the goodness of people is
that where does that exist but then also
also look at what people in the movies
make I mean like is that is that fair
for somebody to make $20 million for a
movie no but for them they're at least
saying they do it for themselves right
there's no illusion that are somehow
doing it for the better R of society
well I guess a lot of actors probably
think they're doing it for the society
right what would de side to be without
Judge
Dread a just awful yeah I that it's
one I I hear about that it's a
SC a million dollars that people donate
go to your own pocket that's wrong well
so the the definition of charity I
thought this was interesting is the
voluntary giving of help typically in
the form of money to those in need so
actually by giving these people people
salaries that are a million dollars
you're actually going against the very
definition of charity of the word so
what do we do do we just not give money
to these I mean those organizations are
doing some good stuff maybe not the
Heritage Foundation when I get HED to do
a charity event I usually donate the
money back to the charity you know
that's that's as a performer right a
communist leftwing radical so I said
usually not not not the big ones not not
if it's a big check not the big ones but
would this affect how you gave if you
saw this full list oh absolutely I would
I would not want to give to these
particular Charities I mean I wouldn't
give to the Heritage Foundation anyway
right but I mean the Boys and Girls Club
is something that I think is a is a
great service but I would want them to
know I would want them to know that I'm
not giving because of this information
yeah is part of the problem also that
people think that these not for-profit
companies that they're all altruistic
but you can be not for- profit and make
a ton of money right your CEOs and all
your high High Lev people can get paid a
ton you're still not per profit medical
marijuana clinics yeah I think that's
how it works I think they can take a
salary and that they have to be
nonprofits technically I think in
California anyway so does that mean that
that aside from just paying salaries
that all the money goes back to the Ser
it's not it's not going back into to pay
like dividends and things like that
that's right okay I well I guess the
point of this was that you should uh put
your money in the medical marijuana
I think that was the takeway of what
Jimmy was trying to say they were
helping in forget that just straight to
us that's right straight to your local
we can buy our pot we're trying to your
local comedians I think that's the way
to do it all right so one more story and
I thought this would be particularly
interesting because I have two comedians
who I like and respect here and who are
actually funny people a rarity these
days uh so a new book is coming out by
Johnny Carson's former lawyer a guy
named Henry bushkin uh who is uh
Carson's lawyer from 1970 to 1988 which
were many of Johnny's prime years right
in there and and he's just bashing
Johnny and of course Johnny's long gone
at this point he's saying he was
difficult to work with a bad husband a
bad father he always carried a gun he
was unhappy blah blah blah uh now first
off what happened to attorney client
privilege isn't there some sort of uh
you're not supposed to do that aren't
you think
that's some of the things that you
listed there are not particularly
attorney client privilege
those are just those are just things
that he observed from spending I think
18 years with Johnny but but he goes
into pretty specific instan exploitative
it's so exploitative I think that's
really unethical I think it's really
unethical so I wanted what I wanted to
talk to you guys about this was just the
comedian aspect of this because
comedians were known to be uh that this
comes from a dark place and we're all
warped and messed up and all this stuff
don't we have a right to that sort of if
we're going to if we're going to make
people laugh and talk about the truth
and all that stuff don't we have a right
to it and then that it shouldn't be
splashed once we're once we're gone well
go ahead you want no I just I mean first
of all I have nothing to hide anybody
wants to write a book about me like
after I'm dead I'm fine I I really don't
care yeah but
um that's one thing when you talk about
you know us being you know dark and and
that type of personality but when he
because don't you think there's sort of
this implication that he was this
friendly guy everyone and what what he's
really what they're trying to do in the
book is be like but look what he really
there was there was a terrific
documentary about Johnny Carson earlier
this year and and I and I worked on the
show and I met him and I conversed with
him to a point and he was not a very
social person and it's not it's not a
secret you know he was an uncomfortable
person and um and it said that in the
documentary but I think and not having
read this book I think that bushin goes
beyond Beyond this and you know when he
talks about trying to break into his uh
wife's ex-wife's apartment I mean that's
illegal I mean that's illegal stuff that
you that's it's completely exploitative
right and also always carrying around a
gun and all that so I mean is this just
another example of just somebody just
trying to make a buck on somebody else's
Talent basically you know what I I will
have to admit that I am glad that his
lawyer has such low standards and no
ethics because it's fun to read this
stuff it I real really Happ to hear that
that Johnny Carson was even more flawed
than I am and you know the fact that he
would be I know that he married three
women named Joanna right right and uh
but the the thing is when he went to his
wife had taken out a apartment she was
leasing an apartment where she would go
and have sexual trrs with her lover and
it turned out her lover was Frank Gord
oh boy the
MVP the MVP your wife is beging the MVP
no wonder Johnny was pissed yeah so and
then uh but it was there there is some
funny insights the way he dealt with the
so one night he's drinking at a bar and
uh he calls up Ed mcmah was right after
he found out his wife was cheating did
you read this book so I read parts of it
there was
exert and so he's sitting there Dr
drinking with Ed and then when the
lawyer shows up he's he turns to Ed and
goes we're done here right Ed and then
Ed just gets off and walks away it was
kind of was like oh hey yeah okay yeah
so uh you know what I mean that's yeah
so okay so this all this stuff is again
from 1970 to 1988 before Twitter and
Facebook and all that stuff and Johnny
clearly had no privacy even then so
should any of us expect anyone that's
even remotely in the public eye at all
should we expect to have any privacy
while we're alive or when we're Al you
know it's it's really up to the ethics
of individuals and there are a lot of
people who who don't respect other
people's privacy and that's the way it's
going to be and that's why I like to
have no secrets because then nobody can
hurt me that's mhm so I could tell
people about my Propecia use so it can't
be used against me yeah um that's what
they'll say about Jimmy when he's long
gone he used that wasn't his real hair
that but it is your real hair it's just
through science thank you so but you
were talking about you know this
revealing what a dark side Johnny Carson
had and you know somehow comedians are
uh I think everyone has dark sides I
think everyone is messed up horribly and
as the comedians just have a talent they
just you we doing something with it
yes Jerry sein I like the way he said
that you he says you know uh he was
talking with Gary Shandling and Gary
Shandling was saying don't you think we
come from a place where we need this
attention we need this that's why we get
on stage that's why and then Jerry
Seinfeld says yeah or we could have
talent that could be that and I agree I
think that comedians are as Jerry would
never admit that he has a dark
side right what's the deal with the dark
side that I don't have that I don't have
but I I think that we all I think
everyone has dark sides and I I think
that's why people connect with those
kind of stories and I just think again
that the comedians have talent to be
able to like make light of them yeah
don't you think but is it hard for
people to people with d with worse you
know if everything's hunky dory in your
life what is that happy families are all
happy in the same way it's unhappy
families are all unhappy uniquely I
don't know if I'm butchering that quote
but so that's why you need you don't
need comedy if everything's hunky dory
in your life that's why I say you know
conservatives don't do comedy they're
the reason we need comedy in the first
place right so that that that I
think that everybody's messed up and
don't take that it is interesting how
there are not there are not really who
are the
conserv when Dennis Miller went
conservative he lost his way you can't
be but he got a lot of money out of Bill
O'Reilly you can't but comedy is
supposed to punch upward right exactly
supposed to that and when it goes
downward it's called bullying and so now
Dennis Miller is a bully he's not
actually a comedian he's not using
comedy in the service of the underdog
he's using comedy in the service of the
bully and that's why he's not a comedian
he's as as Andy Kindler says Dennis
Miller a retired comedian even he would
be able to see right so by the way I
apologize for implying that Jerry
Seinfeld may have had may have a dark
side no it's none of my business no you
acknowledge that Jimmy and you and me
May oh God I mean I have a very such a
dark side yeah I have I was at my
friend's house the other day and he
lives on one of the Canyons and I said
you know what's great about your house
uh if you want to commit suicide you
just walk out and try to cross the
street that's how I look at
things well there you go I we usually
don't end on suicide but I feel like
that was a pretty uh I always end on
suicide pretty solid ending I want to
thank Jimmy D and Kathy ladman oh by the
way our sponsor is koa.com there is a
link right down below you can get up to
75% off pet treats and toys these are
both dog owners oh God I'll do anything
for my dog they've got cat stuff too uh
you can use code RR for 20% off your
next order on top of that uh and follow
these guys on Twitter that's right down
below as well and subscribe I've given
them a lot of instruction a lot you know
they're exhausted they're not going to
do anything all right just shut it
off